go for another
chair change
cousin inspired apparently by
surroundings by his hemingway suite or
heming as he likes to call him
and here we are
the real path
okay one b5 there should be three
castles wesley so of course
can't play all the openings knows the
stuff
let's see if after c3 he will play the
marvel pawn to t5
but i would guess megan's not gonna
allow it's gonna play d3 a4 h h3 one
move of these
we shall see
hamza cook is saying what tournament is
this this is the sun fermin mundial
san fermin
um
in pamplona is the annual festivities
there that typically
involve
things like bull running since that was
not happening this year they thought
what's the closest thing to bull running
it's obviously chess
and here we are hosting a tournament
with some of the world's best players
magnus carson is on site
in pamplona wesley so the other
participants playing from home
and yeah this is the semi-finals level
aronia won the other semi-finals
against digler is waiting
in
the finals
magnus carlsen so far looks well on his
way
to join him there up to zero
but
i've proclaimed magnus winning against
wesley
too
soon many a time wesley
tends to have a way to make it back into
these matches
um
[Music]
yeah the finals also today
7pm
pawn to d4 looks like a natural enough
move wesley went knight a7 tending to go
c5
gaining some control over the center
carlson says
not gonna be able to do it i'll play d4
before you go c5
and
once again nice position for the world
champion
so far seems to be cruising
94 rookie for d5 wesley
going for a tactical solution but magnus
was ready for it with rook takes e6
now
f takes e6 bishop takes c4 looks
horrible so he goes c takes b3
and that was very fast rook takes a6
white is a pawn up count
bc queen c2
one two three four five versus one two
three
four five six
yeah looks like white is a pawn up with
a good solution
with a good position
[Music]
seems like
chess is coming home s is my daughter
[Music]
[Music]
we're having a debate if i can
go upstairs look after
my son nelly's little brother so she can
print out
pictures of princesses i'm saying not
gonna be able to do it i have to watch
this exciting chess match that she does
not seem
to agree with my
my reasoning
um
we have nowhere that's what's good
queen d5
c5
magnus
still in control
takes bishop e3 someone weakening
they're probably not much of an issue
rook b6
nice little trick can't take the queen
because the background mate
and more trickery from magnus feeling
himself a little bit
mr tsushin sook
never
moving the queen just saying you know
what i'll keep making intermediate moves
until
someone cries
rook d7
who's just waiting for white h6 wesley
wisely makes a loof but knight t4 let's
say
or also just h3 or h4
quite a display
[Music]
a5 trying to regain the pawn but the
world champion has it all figured out
goes rook to c6
it takes knight takes
and the rook is hanging the knight is
hanging
there's just
no way
to save the game and wesley resigns
after rook c6
3-0 quite a performance
agnos
having a zip of water